an immortal Great Dane teams up with his
human friends in Skoob an all-new
animated adventure loving loyal and very
very friendly the dog called scooby-doo
is known as the comic companion to
teenage friends who solve spooky
mysteries but how did he first become
involved with the teens and what was
their biggest most challenging mystery
to solve
we'll learn the answers and Scoob as
Scooby and Shaggy meet and join the
intrepid young detectives Fred Velma and
Daphne informing the investigative
agency mystery egg then after they've
solved hundreds of cases they must foil
a diabolical plot revolving around a
ghost dog known as Cerberus discovering
Scooby's secret legacy and their own
epic destiny along the way here's
everything you need to know before you
watch the animated series scooby-doo
where are you was originally broadcast
on Saturday mornings beginning in
September 1969 the show became a huge
success influenced a flock of similar
themed teenage mystery shows and spawned
a wave of spin-off series and
feature-length animated movies over the
decades that followed inspired by the
series two films were released in
theaters Scooby Doo and Scooby Doo two
monsters unleashed voiced by Neil
Fanning Scooby Doo was created by
computer-generated visual effects mixing
with the live-action Freddie Prinze jr.
Sarah Michelle Gellar Matthew Lillard
and Linda Cardellini starred as Fred
Daphne Shaggy and Velma respectively
beginning in 2002 several new animated
series have premiered each winning new
audiences including what's new
scooby-doo shaggy and scooby-doo get a
clue scooby-doo mystery Incorporated be
cool scooby-doo and scooby-doo and guess
who not to mention a number of new
standalone special episodes produced for
home video release all confirming the
incredible popularity of the mystery
loving dog and his friends in this new
film Scooby Doo's best friend shaggy
will be voiced by Will Forte Velma will
be voiced by Gina Rodriguez Zac Efron
will voice Fred Mark Wahlberg wolf voice
Blue Falcon and Amanda Seyfried will
voice
Daphne and don't worry veteran actor
Frank Welker who has brought Scooby to
life in a variety of television shows
and feature-length movies returns as the
voice of the beloved Great Dane Emmy
Award nominated animation expert Tony
servo nee directed the film this marks
his third scooby-doo project after
directing scooby-doo and kiss rock and
roll mystery and scooby-doo abracadabra
do so now you know and now you can go
watch Scoob exclusively on digital
platforms including Fandango now
beginning on Friday May 15 created
[Music]